Film Courage: Jeff, you recently wrote a
book and I was wondering if you could tell
me the title of it first?
Jeff Leisawitz: Not ***ing Around: The No
***hit Guide For Getting Your Creative Dreams
Off The Ground.
Film Courage: Okay.
I like the title.
But why the title?
Jeff Leisawitz: Why the title?
Well it’s straight to the point and it pretty
much says what the book is about in one line.
Film Courage: So where were you when you
decided to come up with the idea and was there
something in your life that triggered this
in you where you said “You know what?
Jeff this is no more NFA.”
Which I know is your catchphrase and is really
cool, anybody who hears it knows okay, it’s
a kick in the ***. It means let’s get
going.
But did this happen to you?
Did something happen?
Jeff Leisawitz: Well, I have always (generally)
been NFA my whole life without knowing it
was called that.
I’ve always been pretty motivated and ambitious
to do things, mostly creative things and business
ideas.
Even as a kid I got into music and played
in lots of bands and got a four track and
that kind of stuff.
I wanted to move to LA and become a rock star.
I did move to LA but I didn’t quite become
a rock star, but that’s okay.
But this book happened sort of by accident.
I had a free Saturday or Sunday morning one
day and I coffeed-up at a local Seattle coffee
shop and I just started writing as I often
do.
I wrote one of the chapters in the book.
When I was done I was like “You know, this
would be a good idea for a book for just empowering
creatives.”
And what I realized after I wrote the book
was that everything (well, not everything)
but many things in my life were actually leading
up to this book.
So for instance I have been a creative person
my whole life.
A musician, a filmmaker, a writer, photographer,
etc.
But I’ve also been into empowering people
my whole life.
I was a music journalist when I was empowering
other musicians.
I’m a teacher of songwriting at a college
up near Tacoma, near Seattle.
I’m a life coach.
I practice something called NLP (Neuro-linguistic
re-patterning) which is talk therapy or counseling
to help people untangle the subconscious blocks
that keep them down in various different ways.
So after I wrote this book I kind of thought
about and was like “You know what?
This is actually my mission.
It’s like being creative and empowering.”
But I didn’t know that until I wrote the
book.
If that makes any sense?
Film Courage: It does.
Did you share the idea for the book with anyone?
Jeff Leisawitz: Sure.
Initially, a friend of mine Steve we came
up with the term NFA probably a couple of
years before I wrote the book.
But we come up with lots of weird words and
terms.
And then this one just resurfaced so it seemed
like a good idea for a title.